si vous battez benjamin castaldi il
n'aura pas gagné la voiture si vous
perdez il repartira avec la voiture
isabelle on me dit on me dit qu'ils
avaient les blessés ah ouais donc on va
payer on va payer son remplaçant a mano
qui bat chimiques taper j'appelle arsène
bulard le champion du monde des lourds
légers
[Applaudissements]
oh
c'est l'action du groupe français par
garder bon dans cet essai d'histoire
c'était samedi soir à marseille une
réunion de boxe organisé par notre ami
thierry cheleman le directeur des sports
de canal plus et mon ami sébastien
acariès qui a fait une réunion
exceptionnelle samedi soir sur canal
plus et tu es devenu champion du monde
des lourds-légers un combat exceptionnel
je sais qu'ils étaient été formidable
avec ton adversaire après franchement je
te jure
ils sont le respect d'abord tu mérites
mais il faut le respect voilà parce que
c'est un sport très dur j'ai c'est vrai
et pur très dur il faut rester humble
voilà il faut respecter l'adversaire
magna malgré ça on fait la guerre sur le
plus et un belge ont l'homme fort les
belges et il a fait un super combat il
est très jeune et je pense qu'il va
aller très loin c'est ce que tu as dit
et toi tu es champion du monde des
lourds-légers c'est énorme ce que tu as
accompli
regardez c'était samedi soir juste après
on va voir si benjamin cassel c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah ouais
c'est
les fier de toi non monsieur tapé scène
tu vas voir 2 et 6 2 et 570 sabbath 14
secondes 12 7 72 02 15 g si je dois
acheter cette voiture pour castaldi sony
je me suis fait très mal et cgt annonce
alors si tu gagnes ta l'a fait faire ta
la ceinture à toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]